[Musique]
le Danemark c'est doté de cible de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre parmi
les plus ambitieuses au monde moins 70%
d'ici 2030 par rapport au niveau de 1990
c'est beaucoup plus audacieux qu'ici et
là-bas contrairement au Canada
l'agriculture a aussi des cibles
contraignantes à atteindre les fermiers
danois devront réduire de moitié les
émissions de leurs entreprises c'est
énorme l'une des façons que les Danois
ont trouvé pour y arriver c'est de miser
sur la biométhanisation une approche qui
fait aussi son chemin au Québec
la région d'iceberg au Danemark est
considérée par les Danois comme un havre
de paix certains disent même que c'est
un coin de pays bénit des dieux bordé
par la mer du Nord d'un côté et de
l'autre et la bombe en terre nourricière
au Danemark on compte plus de 13
millions de cochons soit plus du double
de la population c'est un des cinq plus
importants exportateur de ports dans le
monde dans cette étape nous avons une
production annuelle de cent mille ports
dans certaines régions agricoles comme
Asberg les producteurs de bétail sont
aussi en quelque sorte des producteurs
d'énergie grâce aux déjections de leur
balai la ferme de Hans Hool Henson en
est un exemple une fois par semaine le
fermier vide ses canaux souterrains ou
s'écoulent le lisier la matière est
envoyée dans des cuves à l'extérieur
puis un camion bien pompé la matière
fécale et la livre dans cette usine de
biomécanisation
nous sommes à la plus grande usine de
biomécanisation au monde ici nous
transformons 700000 tonnes de biomasse
chaque année
est un leader européen en
bioméhanisation ici on transforme des
résidus agroalimentaires industriels et
agricoles
les résidus sont versées dans de grandes
cubes appelées biodigester on laisse
fermenter pendant environ 40 jours la
matière bio dégradée permet de produire
du GNR du gaz naturel renouvelable et du
gaz carbonique utilisé pour les boissons
gazeuses et ce qui reste dans le fond de
la cuve appelé digesta est utilisé comme
fertilisant il est ensuite redistribué
au fermier pour nature energy cette
circularité est le cœur de son modèle
d'affaires avec la biométhanisation on
fait du gaz propre mais on valorise
aussi les nutriments pour faire de
l'engrais propres c'est une économie
circulaire parfaite on élimine l'énergie
fossile et les engrais chimiques c’est
vraiment bon pour le climat nous
invitons toujours les agriculteurs
locaux à investir avec nous dans les
projets afin que les populations locales
aient un aussi grand sentiment
d'appartenance que nous à l'usine
le GNR permet de réduire les GES de deux
façons en remplaçant une énergie fossile
par une énergie renouvelable et en
évitant les émissions de méthane liées à
l'enfouissement des matières résiduelles
organiques et à l'entreposage des
déjections animales
affirme tout faire pour être cohérente
avec sa mission écologique par exemple
la cinquantaine de fermes qui alimente
cet usine sont dans un rayon de 25 km le
but réduire la distance parcourue par
les camions et ainsi améliorer son bilan
carbone afin de ne pas importuner le
voisinage l'usine contient toutes les
matières odorantes à l'intérieur de ces
installations et pour offrir du GNR à
faible coût nettoyage mis sur des
installations de grande taille
nous avons la possibilité de construire
de petites ou de grandes usines mais il
y a une certaine économie d'échelle à
faire des gens qui travaillent ici ont
le même salaire indépendamment de la
quantité de gaz que nous produisons nous
options pour des centrales qui
produisent une grande quantité d'énergie
à bon
alors que la production porcine est
souvent montrée du doigt par les
environnements à lescom étant polluants
ancestime que c'est un moyen d'amenuiser
les impacts sur l'environnement ça fait
du bien parce que nous pouvons
contribuer à la réduction des GES tout
en diversifiant nos revenus c'est une
situation qui profite à tous
c'est que la biomécanisation parce que
ces usines restent des installations
industrielles venant avec leur lot de
danger explosion et déversements des
environnementsalistes s'inquiète aussi
de la possible présence de bactéries
parasites et résidus médicament dans le
digestat produit qui pourrait contaminer
les sols
energy possède 13 usines au Danemark le
gouvernement danois ne les ane pas sur
l'aide octroyée pour développer la
filiale subventions gouvernementale
généreuse et formalités administrative
allégée car au Danemark la
bioméhanisation est au cœur de sa
transition écologique déjà 30% du gaz
dans le réseau énergétique est
renouvelable et nature energy fournit à
lui seul un tiers du GNR oui nous
développons l'entreprise pour pouvoir
produire et construire annuellement plus
d'usine à travers le monde nous avons
comme objectif d'avoir une usine de
biogaz à tous les 50 km pour valoriser
tous les déchets organiques que nous
produisons
le géant danois voit grand et le Québec
est dans Samir en décembre dernier
nature energy et NRJ ont signé une
entente de plus d'un milliard de dollars
pour y construire une dizaine d'usines
au Québec une entente qui permettra à
immerger d'atteindre plus facilement la
cible de 10 % de GNR dans son réseau
d'ici 2030 cible imposée par le
gouvernement du Québec
ici la biomécanisation en est encore
assez balbutiements l'industrie
s'organise en avril dernier à
Drummondville 400 personnes ont
d'ailleurs participé au tout premier
forum sur le GNR au Québec quelques
usines seulement existent et traitent
surtout des résidus organiques
domestiques une seule traite des résidus
agricoles et c'est à Warwick qu'elle est
installée
mais pour le passé c'était pas vraiment
accessible point de vue ou pire
rentabilité le contexte est plus
favorable c'est ainsi qu'on a fait
connaissance avec Coop carbone qui nous
ont proposé régionalement ce beau projet
là
plus producteur laitiers et un fromager
c'est la première coopérative agricole
au Québec dédiée à la production de GNR
une idée devenue réalité grâce au
soutien de la Coop carbone c'est une
coopérative de solidarités
principale c'est la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre avec ce genre de projet
collaboratif où on regroupe plusieurs
groupes pour faire un projet de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre le GNR
produit par la coop est vendue à énergie
ici le procédé pour produire du GNR et
sensiblement le même coût Danemark la
récolte par camion se fait quelques fois
par semaine chez les producteurs le
camionneur qui récolte les résidus
agricoles ils laissent du digestat au
passage ça devient digesto avec une
valeur nutritionnelle plus disponible
pour les plantes un produit plus
homogène ce qui rend les choses
davantage intéressantes pour nous
les opérations sont aussi très
similaires mais contrairement au
Danemark la Coop mis sur des
installations de petites tailles pour
nous c'est important que le projet soit
accepté par la communauté que ce
projet-là soit intégré dans le paysage
qu'on n'arrive pas avec un monstre en
campagne pour le fermier un projet comme
celui-ci est indéniablement positif en
plus d'en retirer des bénéfices
financiers il a la conviction de
contribuer à la protection de
l'environnement c'est non négligeable
ce qu'on est aujourd'hui que on se pose
au quotidien contre les hausses de prix
mais tout est bienvenu c'est un plus
value qu'on peut aller chercher qu'on
n'avait pas avant mais certains
environnementalistes au pays ont des
réserves en lien avec la
biométhanisation il s'inquiète de voir
un plus grand nombre de camions
circulaient sur les routes d'autres
craignent que la mince proportion de GNR
injecté dans le réseau donne
l'impression au public que le gaz
naturel est complètement vert une forme
d'écho blanche en Chima la cour à grille
énergie Warwick produit 2,3 millions de
mètres cubes de GNR par an assez pour
chauffer 1000 maisons en une année
l'usine de 13 millions de dollars à pu
bénéficier de différentes subventions 4
années se sont écoulées entre l'idéation
du projet et la première injection de
GNR dans le réseau d'énergie nos
premiers projets ça amène toujours son
lot de complexité on a eu beaucoup
beaucoup d'intérêt de la part des
gouvernements dans la nature du projet
dans ce que ça apportait en termes de
bénéfices environnementaux mais
économique avec un peu plus d'un million
de vaches et plus de 7 millions de porc
au Québec le potentiel de croissance de
la production de GNR est importante
selon le professeur Sylvain mais à
certaines conditions on peut déjà dire
si on a un projet il faut réduire les
délais pour mettre en oeuvre ses projets
là en ce moment-là on peut avoir des
projets des fois ça fera 5-6 ans c'est
beaucoup trop long donc ça on peut on
peut régler ça à court terme pour ce
faire il faudrait des subventions
bonifiées et simplifier les démarches
administratives tout en respectant les
normes environnementales quelques
mesures qui selon le professeur pourrait
aider le développement de la
biométhanisation au Québec des meilleurs
habitudes que nous au niveau de la
récupération des matières organiques
résidentiels il faut développer cette
culture-là de valoriser
nous organique puis c'est un peu ce qui
doit être l'enjeu au Québec
[Musique]
veut réduire de 37,5% ces émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2030 par
rapport à leur niveau de 1990 et
atteindre la carbone neutralité d'ici
2050 le secteur agricole et le cinquième
plus grand émetteur de GES au pays pour
plusieurs la production de GNR est un
des moyens à considérer pour aider à
protéger la planète l'agriculture on est
au début de la chaîne c'est que pour
nous c'est important que notre métier
soit bien partager aux citoyens qu'on
aille une bonne visibilité justement ce
projet-là ça fait partie de cette
stratégie là d'être transparent on va le
citoyen qui sait qu'est-ce qu'ils
mangent qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a
sur la terre puis que nous aussi on fait
des efforts pour soutenir la planète